Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we're talking about gifts.
A lot of people are thinking about gifts.
Giving is in the air.
Your collar is doing
something that I could.
Well, because,
I could help you with or you like that?
Is it undulating?
You like that?
Thank you.
I kinda feel like, I just wanna say-
I just wanna get my neck
covered a little bit.
I just feel like there
are limits to the coziness
that you should experience in public.
And I feel like you've crossed the line.
I love crossing that line.
Well, I'm just saying that,
I just feel like you've
crossed a cultural line
and you're making other
people feel uncomfortable
because you're so comfortable.
I'm a boundary pusher.
So we ask you Mythical beasts
to tell us the best gift
you've ever received
and who gifted it to you, implying that,
hey, we want a little bit of a story,
as much as Twitter can stomach.
And we said we might discuss it
on an episode "Ear Biscuits".
This is the 313th episode
and we are discussing that.
But we're not discussing
that this is the 313th episode other than
what you just did.
That's not
what I was referring to.
We're also gonna be talking
about our best gifts ever,
and maybe some of the
gifts that we've received
over the years, or maybe
even given over the years,
that come up as we tell
some of your gifts.
It is the season for giving.
And if your wife has a
birthday of December 18th.
Ooh goodness.
Man, this time of year,
like literally...
Pressure.
Like right now, 'cause at the
time we're recording this,
I still had a few weeks and...
No, it seems like, by your
body posture you have no plans.
You know what'll help?
Put your collar up, just for a second,
just while you're talking about this,
just kind of experience it.
There you go.
Well, the thing,
A little protection.
the thing that-
Makes you feel a little...
This is what happens to me.
More, creative.
I wish that she would
change her birth date.
I've lobbied.
I've lobbied for this and
she says it's not acceptable.
Because I'm like.
I get it.
This time of year,
this time of year is so busy for us,
it's like everything just gets
piled at the end of the year.
I don't remember to do
so many other things.
I start seeing areas of my house
where like things are building up,
and then I see areas of my inbox
that things are building up,
and then I went like,
Oh, I have to...
And don't look inward.
I have to,
Yeah, that's how I feel.
I have to give something
for my wife's birthday
and for Christmas.
And it matters to her, so it...
No, here's the thing.
It doesn't?
Well, there are two disparate
realities within my wife,
she's a complex woman.
Number one, she really cares about gifts.
She really cares about giving
and she really cares about
receiving gifts, naturally.
That is her natural disposition
'cause she comes from
a family of gift givers
and extravagant gift givers,
and extravagant gift receivers.
Meaning that, when her
family receives gifts
from each other, there's
lots of emotional release.
And I come from a family where my mom
like gets everything for
herself and just says,
"You got me this for my birthday.
You got me this for Christmas."
And she gave up.
Ain't no arguing with that
from you, right?
She gave up on my dad
and my brothers a long time ago.
I mean, and we actually
want to, we wanna give,
but she's just like,
"You're not gonna get it right."
So I'm just gonna get stuff from myself.
And then also in my
family, you know my dad.
So it's just like, you give my dad a gift,
it's not like, you're not gonna get some,
you're not gonna get the response
that you're looking for.
You know what I'm saying?
You're not gonna get this,
you get "Oh, I feel like" -
What response are you gonna get?
'cause you know what,
the response my dad gives.
Yeah, I think you can relate to this.
He gets the shirt and it's just like,
"Where do you expect me to wear this?"
Your dad does super honest.
My dad does just enough to
feel some social obligation,
but not actually make you feel
great about what you got him.
And listen.
Because he's-
And I have a very similar personality.
Is he kind of,
he's giving as much as he
can muster for the gifter
because for him, it's like,
gifts don't resonate
with him, maybe with you.
And I don't think with
me that much, usually.
Gifts are resonating more
with me as I get older.
But the interesting thing about Jesse
is that this is the environment.
This is the nature and the nurture
that she's bringing to the
table, but she married me.
And I think I changed her
baseline level of expectations.
Now, as I've established-
Changed, you could come
up with a stronger verb.
I am a giver in many ways.
And I actually, I like to
give, but the thing is,
is I have a little bit of,
she's got opinions and she's got taste
and I don't necessarily have taste.
And so when you, so...
Wow, a woman with opinions and taste.
What ends up happening
is I may not respond
as heartily as she wants me
to do something that is given to me.
And then I may not, but
over 20 years of marriage,
her expectations have centered
in a place.
Sunk.
No, centered is the
word that I want to use.
They've become more realistic.
They have descended
And now she-
into a pocket of despair.
In fact, you know what she told me?
She told me this two nights ago, she said,
she was like, "I am so excited
about your Christmas gift."
She was like,
"I'm giving you"
That you're giving her?
No, she's giving me.
She said, "I'm giving you the best...
It is the best gift you
will have ever received."
Crap!
And she didn't even
know we were doing this.
And then she said,
"You know what?
You shouldn't even get me anything."
Because it won't top it?
Yeah.
That's what she said,
"You shouldn't even get me anything
because it just will pale in comparison."
And you whipped out the
contract, you're like,
let me get that in writing,
I've already worked it up.
Yeah, so I'm still going.
And actually she will say,
"Two things have happened."
That's a lot of pressure on you.
You feel cool about that?
I'm fine because-
'Cause she's a good gifter.
The point that I'm getting to
is that her expectations
have centered, lowered, sunk,
whatever you wanna say.
My gifting ability
and my listening ability-
Has gotten better.
And the graph of gifting expectations
and gifting ability has some...
We've met in the middle,
I've gotten better.
Her expectations have lowered
and I've actually hit it out
of the park a couple of times.
Most recently for her birthday last year,
which you were a part of when
I did the whole cameo thing
with all the friends and family
and the celebrities.
Yeah, that was a good gift.
And then I gave her something else too.
And I've kind of forgotten at this point.
But anyway, I don't
feel that much pressure
from her.
You wrote her a song, dude.
Oh, I wrote her a song.
Yeah, yeah, I see, I see.
I'm getting better, man, but
I'm also getting forgetful.
I totally forgot, I
wrote her a song for her-
Well, you better hope she forgot,
'cause you don't want her comparing that
to every other gift.
But we talked about it at the time.
It's like, you're gonna have to go back
into a trough to recenter the baseline.
Well, I don't feel a lot
of pressure from her,
I feel pressure on myself
of like, I gotta do this.
I got to do something special.
For her birthday she will
be with all her family
and my family though
because we're flying
back to North Carolina.
So that'll be special.
And I did take care with the
help of my sister-in-law,
who volunteered, I didn't ask her,
to set up a special private
dinner in some place.
So we're gonna do that, that'll be nice.
And then trying to figure out
something to add on top of that.
Anyway, I'm feeling pretty good about it,
but I still have no ideas about Christmas.
Collar down.
Collar down, okay, here we go.
Now we're getting into it.
Yeah, with me and Christy,
it's never been that
charged around the holidays.
It is a bit more of a focus on the kids
and on like the struggle to
get things for the family.
The conflict we have is that like,
it has defaulted to her to get gifts
for not only her family,
but my extended family.
And that's not necessarily fair
and has been a source of tension.
I mean, the solution has been
to slowly just stop giving 'em gifts.
Just like we give you
the gift of our presence
and something that, not that just like,
I'm gonna give you
something to say you got it.
But like, even if it's just a picture
and given a lot of my
family merch is a big win,
I've discovered.
We started doing that.
We're doing that again this year.
Well, I hope they're not
listening to spoiler,
but yeah-
I think they've come to expect it.
And I'm talking about
the nieces and nephews.
Yeah, nieces-
I'm not like getting my mom a hoodie.
I mean, I think your dad wants a hoodie.
Oh, definitely, anything to
continue to get recognized,
he wants to wear.
Yeah, 'cause for Christy it's Mother's Day
and her birthday are like
very, very close together.
And it seems like they're
right on the heels of Valentine's Day.
So there's like this triple
threat of disappointment
from the Linkster.
Right on the heels.
Right on the heels is kind of pushing it.
Yeah February 14th,
and then her birthday May 13th.
Yeah, you're like half the year
is on the heels.
Three months later, but...
Yeah, you got about a
quarter to prepare for that.
J's Blue Sunshine said,
"This prompt from you guys,
I can actually contribute to
because the answer's easy, Roxy."
She post a picture, "A teeny tiny,
barely a palmful of chihuahua puppy
my momma and daddy got
me for my 19th birthday."
Okay, so you're an adult and
you're getting this puppy.
"Roxy grew to two and a half pounds
and was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
We spent 14 years together."
Makes me wanna tear up.
It's like, I mean,
we know what, you start talking
about dogs that are gone,
but like, you remember
those 14 years together
and that super cute picture.
But can you love a dog
that's two and a half pounds
as much as you can love
one that's 20 pounds?
Definitely.
That is a big-
Of course you can.
That is a big life altering gift.
I know when, after my pop-pop passed away,
my nanny was gifted a poodle,
which was not a puppy,
but like a full grown poodle for Christmas
that was named Nicholas for St. Nick.
I don't know if she changed the name
or if that was just a coincidence.
And she didn't, I mean,
it's kinda dicey when
you give somebody a pet
and they're not asking for a pet.
I would say, very dicey.
Especially when it's an old woman,
it's like-
When was the last time
she had a dog, period.
My Papa had dogs always,
but they were never house dogs.
Yeah, yard dogs.
They were yard dogs and she...
It was not like a joyful
moment when she got that dog.
But that dog changed her life.
Yeah, the people who gave her that gift,
which I guess was like,
Theresa and-
Family, family.
No, you're on the wrong
side of the family.
Oh it was, nanny.
Yeah nanny.
Trying to get that now.
Yeah, 'cause you remember little Nicholas,
the little white poodle.
Oh yeah.
He was good.
I had been picturing
that after pop-pop died
that nana had been given-
No, I call 'em both pop-pop
so my dad's side pop-pop Neal.
When he basically went
for the most part blind,
he was given a dog named Bacardi
and then that dog kinda changed his life.
And that Bacardi is still with nana now.
Did they know the reference?
Yeah, but they didn't
change the name.
Good.
So getting a pet companion
can be a life altering gift in a good way,
I guess, in a bad way,
but then maybe not, maybe you
just do something about it.
You don't hear about those,
at least in this props.
Yeah, I wanted to give
some cat to the dogs,
some tip for the tat.
Carter Hastings said, "My family
pooled some money together
and formed the 'get Carter
a cat fund' one Christmas
so I could go out and
choose a little friend
and pay for all of the
necessary supplies."
Lots of expense goes along
with it and ongoing expense.
"Dave is the best little
guy I could ever ask for."
Here he is, the cat in
the box with the cute,
little pink nose on the white snout.
And then the gray.
I think that if you know that somebody,
I mean easily, if you know
that somebody wants an animal.
Yeah, it's tough to just
give one, as a prescription.
It worked out for nanny,
but there was dicey there
for the first month probably.
I mean, it's not necessarily
good for the animal
as well if it's like-
I think this Carter thing
does highlight a really good system
I mean, you lose the
surprise of the moment,
but like for me, my personality type,
you know I want to pick out the dog
or the cat that I'm gonna spend
the next 14 to 20 years with.
Oh, you know what?
just an epiphany I might be having,
and this gonna be a
huge disappointment now
if it doesn't happen, not for me.
Well, my wife doesn't listen
to this podcast very often.
I don't think-
Thank God.
Not unless like people
on Twitter tell her to.
So if you're a fan of Jessie on Twitter,
don't tell her about this.
You wanna get her a dog?
No, what if she's getting me a dog?
That's it.
That would be consistent
with the level of excitement
that she...
'Cause she knows that I-
Of all the things that I do
and the subjects I
broad from this podcast,
what you're doing right
now, I would not do.
I'm just being honest,
when it comes to gifts,
and this'll come up in a story later-
You know what? It's not gonna happen.
I hate, like-
I know-
If someone wants to surprise me,
I hate knowing that I
didn't surprise them.
Like I want to make them happy.
She wants to make you so happy.
But here's thing,
I'm just thinking about the logistics
of when our Christmas has to take place
before we travel.
Yeah.
And the fact that we've
already got a board to Barbara
for a couple of weeks when
we go to North Carolina.
Yeah it's probably that.
So it's like you can't get a puppy,
you can't get a puppy
right before Christmas
and then not take care of it immediately
as your own family,
can't be in his own home.
So it wouldn't surprise me
because I'm on team second dog.
It's just, the amount of emotional energy
and sort of logistical
fortitude that it takes
to make it happen is something-
To get over that hump.
So like, that's really the
gift is I got over that hump,
here's the dog.
So, the more you think about it,
you don't think logistically?
It hit me that it would be a perfect gift
and it would-
Well also-
It would match her level of excitement.
But it's too far in advance too, right?
I mean, does she pick out?
Well, not, I guess you
could pick out a dog
and then months later-
What if the dog
is already in my house?
What if it's in a cabinet somewhere?
What if the dog is
wearing a Barbara costume
and Barbara has been
boarded this whole time.
She has been acting strange,
she fricking peed in our bed.
Welcome to my world.
Then there was like,
I'm taking my squishy
mellow out of the dryer
for the second time,
because Jasper's peeing
on my squishy mellows.
Okay, well,
Barbara has been well behaved in this area
for a very long time.
Yeah, I know.
She rings her little bell
when she wants to go out.
She like rings it a couple of times-
She is upset about something,
what is it?
Well-
It's the fact that
it's not Barbara
or that she knows there's
another dog coming.
Have you picked out,
have you agreed on the
type of dog you wanna get?
Because that really starts
to support this theory.
We're not as specific,
like we don't want to
do a Barbara lookalike
that's slightly a different color.
We having a-
A peanut butter version of Barbara?
We have not like,
the McLaughlin's don't get that specific.
The only thing I've said is
I don't want a big dog that
requires a lot of activity
because-
It could be a dog man
I don't think that our family
would support that in the right way.
We're not good enough at dog-walking.
We need a dog that doesn't need
a whole lot of energy output.
Do you want me
to ask Christy?
No, don't even...
In fact just forget I
ever brought this up.
It's not gonna be a dog.
I'm gonna forget any stuff you brought up.
We will get a dog eventually but-
I'll literally forget about it.
I don't think that that's it.
I have a button in my brain
that if you tell me to
forget about something,
especially something you said, poop!
I've forgotten about it.
Just like the "Men In Black" button?
Like, I have one of those.
Okay.
So I've forgotten about it.
Or like, "What We Do In The Shadows?"
So don't be mad at me.
You will forget about this conversation.
Yeah, call it a Jedi mind trick.
Yeah, they don't make people forget...
It's not gonna be a dog,
but it wouldn't be a bad gift
because-
I hope it is.
I think the things that are necessary
when you're thinking about
giving somebody an animal
is you have to know that
they've already expressed
a willingness to invite an animal
into your home and life.
But just to round things off with the pet,
Erin tweeted at us,
"My aunt and uncle"
I'm saying aunt.
No, you're assuming that they must be from
a certain part of the
country or something.
This not the South.
"My aunt and uncle got
me goats in fifth grade!
I bred them and managed a
small herd for eight years.
Looking back, the best part was that
they lived at my grandma's house
because I lived in the city limits.
It let me get a lot closer with my grandma
for going over there every day."
That's cool.
Not only is it,
I mean, I appreciate the
connection with grandma,
but if every fifth grader in America
could be given a herd of goats.
Well, you have to make the herd.
You're just given a couple.
Forget about all the difficulties
of where they would be
and what they would be fed.
But I'm just saying,
if you can have every fifth grader
have the responsibility of a herd of goats
for the next eight years.
So basically until they
graduate high school.
I like this as a social program.
All our problems as a
society would go away.
I feel that.
Do you understand?
Everything that we argue about,
everything that people get
so bent out of shape about
would completely go away.
And if I ever have the privilege and honor
to run for president,
my platform is gonna be
goats for every fifth grader.
And you know what?
The environment's helped
too, 'cause they eat trash.
Well, they also will like,
they can mow lawns and stuff,
but they can get out of control.
So we might have to do some
sort of cooperative thing
where there's like,
this class of fifth graders
has a herd of goats,
I don't know, I need my team
to work on the logistics,
but just know that that's my platform,
goats for fifth graders.
As long as my team-
Okay, we're gonna talk a little bit more
about your gifts and our gifts,
but speaking of gifts,
we want you to know that you people
who wait till the last minute
to get stuff for yourself,
Mythical stuff for yourself
and for others, maybe for the holidays,
you're in luck because we
have amazon.com/mythical.
Yes, you can get the stuff
that we've got over there,
which is mostly or entirely different
from the stuff you can
get at mythical.com,
and it's all prime shipping.
♪ Prime prime prime prime ♪
So as fast as Prime gets to you
is as fast as that Mythical
merch can get to you, okay.
Or get to your loved ones.
I'm gonna do it again, Kiko.
♪ Prime prime prime prime ♪
And I'm never gonna do that again.
That's the official sound of
Amazon Prime and not really.
You know what I was trying to do, right?
It was like a air horn.
Yeah, the DJ air horn thing.
Yeah.
Okay, this one from JustKate_tm.
"When I turned 15,
my grandma got me a sewing machine
and gave me lessons at her house.
Seven years later, I have
a degree in costume design
and I work at a theater running wardrobe."
I love this.
I might have to incorporate
sewing into my goat plan at this point.
You can choose between
goats or a sewing machine.
I feel that too man.
Okay, all right,
do you wanna run with me?
Co-president?
Co, yes.
The first ever co-presidents,
they'd change the constitution for us.
You know what?
I kinda wanna be vice-president,
I kinda want-
The lack of responsibility.
The heck, yeah.
Yeah, low pressure, got it.
I love this.
Lily actually asked for
sewing machine and got it.
How'd that go?
And she did sew some stuff
and she still has this
like handy thing about her,
but she never uses the
sewing machine that much,
instead she would do more
like hand embroidery,
which is actually pretty amazing,
unlike book packs, backpacks,
book sacks.
Book packs.
What do you call it?
Book sacks is what you call that.
Jean pockets, book sacks, all that stuff.
But yeah, the fact that
her grandma gave her
something that just, it
either changed or accelerated,
maybe even determined her
life trajectory to this point,
with a degree in costume
design, working at a theater,
like just kind of putting
the kindling together
in the form of a gift and then like hid,
the receiver brings the spark
and it fans into a flame
that is a pivotal point in their lives.
You can't hope for more
from a gift, right?
Yeah, and some people might be like,
"Well man, if somebody
doesn't ask for something
and you're just forcing it on 'em,
trust me and kids ain't gonna do
what kids don't wanna do."
Right.
So Kate obviously had a predisposition
for enjoying this
and it was maybe even in her blood
and maybe that's what her
grandmother recognized.
I try to give,
but my version of this is giving
my kids musical instruments
and putting them in piano lessons.
Lincoln is interested in production.
So it's like, what can
we do to foster that
and to see where it goes,
Lily's taken more to it.
Like she's saying, when she
comes home for Christmas,
she's gonna take her guitar
back with her to campus.
And she also has a keyboard,
but it's so big, she
didn't wanna take that
until she has more of a space
where she can take that and the cat,
I think by the time she's
gonna take that cat,
I don't know if I'm gonna
want her to take the cat,
and you didn't hear that from me.
I'm just starting to understand.
I mean, this is a whole
different discussion.
I can tell by your sweater
that you understand cats.
I'll leave it at this,
Lincoln and I have many conversations
about understanding how
to connect with soccer
is totally different than the dogs,
but seeing some success
there is rewarding.
I'll leave it at that.
Give a good life-changing gift lately?
Well, it's interesting
because I don't know,
my Locke is like me in that
he's all over the place, right?
And interested in so
many different things.
And so he has bought
himself with his money
that he has earned at
his job, three guitars.
Now one was, according to him,
the first one that was stolen,
but we're pretty sure it
was just left on the corner-
By him?
By him,
in the neighborhood somewhere because...
What is that app that our wives go on?
Nextdoor.
And it was like,
somebody had found a guitar
on the side of the street
and then-
You didn't retrieve it?
Well, but Jessie was going back months
and saw it.
Oh.
And so then when she
reached out to the guy,
the guy didn't respond.
I think it was because dude,
I put this up here like months ago
and now you're reaching out to me.
I've already pawned this thing, whatever.
Pawned it, pawned it.
It was a cheap guitar.
And he's got like his amp,
I'll tell you about the amps,
these new amps that communicate
with an app on your phone.
Of course they do.
And you can dial in a sound like,
I want this guitar to sound exactly like-
Jimmy Page?
John Mayer's guitar
in this particular song.
So like slow dancing in a burning room
like that ryth, right?
Yeah.
And then Locke light plays it in,
it doesn't sound like John Mayer,
but it sounds like you 17-year-old
learning how to play guitar,
trying to play John Mayer.
But the guitar sound, the
tone is exactly the same.
And he's like, dad, what
about Merle Haggard?
So-and-so so-and-so and then-
♪ Could be holding you tonight ♪
That that's is that really
awesome, like tele sound.
But you hope to give 'em
gifts that he takes off.
Right, what I'm getting at is-
You can't control it.
With Locke and the Shepherd's
playing piano, violin,
and now is learning guitar.
And so they're kinda doing that,
but I think a guitar would be a good gift
for Shepherd at this point,
because he's just playing
the ones that's cool.
There might be three
laying around, or at least two.
He ain't done electrics though.
Oh.
But one of the better,
this is an opportunity for me
to talk about one of my favorite gifts
that I got, because Jessie
gave me my Nirvana hand pan.
Nirvana is the brand.
I say that because
they're based in Glendale,
local business, but my light hand drum.
Oh yes, but the musical instrument.
Again, I requested this,
it would have been a great gift,
but it's one of those things
that like I had particulars.
I knew which one I
wanted because she, okay,
I had played somebody a
friend's hand pan a while back.
This is such a California conversation.
Years ago, right?
And then, so Jessie ended up getting me-
I played my friend's hand pan,
I had some opinions about it.
It's not just California,
Colorado, we could do this too.
Yeah, Asheville.
Asheville,
there's lots of places in the world.
She got me a Russian tongue drum,
which is that you've seen
that thing in my house,
which is about that big.
And it's like a metal,
it looks like a spaceship
and it just has these little
U cut out like tongues
and then you hit it with a mallet
or a little yarn wrap thing.
And I liked that, but it wasn't the,
I can get into the rhythm
and play with my hands.
It wasn't a hand pan, right?
If you hit that thing with your hand,
it doesn't make a lot of noise.
So I found the people making them locally.
I researched all the keys
and I wanted to get the Celtic scale,
mostly because of my
Scotch Irish background.
And it seemed like a good place.
So I had these ideas,
oh, let's do the D minor.
And so then she got it,
and it was an amazing gift.
I find that most of the gifts
that are my favorite gifts
are the ones that were my idea,
and I selected and then
told somebody, what...
That's basically what my mom does.
I mean, how often does somebody?
And again, my wife apparently
thinks that this is what she's done.
That she thinks that she
struck gold this year.
We're gonna find out, I'll report back.
A totally unexpected un-requested gift
that is as fulfilling as one
that you curated for yourself.
That's the ultimate gift.
But I don't have many examples of that.
I don't have many examples
of favorite gifts,
it was difficult for me.
I just don't think
that's my love language.
So it doesn't resonate.
But like the biggest gift that is,
I mean, has to rank up there pretty high.
And you'll have to help me
remember how to tell this story,
because I haven't told
this story in so long that-
Don't have a great memory.
I gotta pull it back up.
So I was 15-years-old
and I was just looking
forward to getting my license
and getting a car.
And there was a pickup
truck on the used-car lot,
just a few blocks
from my nana and pop-pop
house in Lillington.
And I was like, "That's the truck I want."
Candy apple red,
A 1987.
1987 Nissan pickup
with a chrome wheels, pretty redneck,
like it wasn't four-wheel drive,
but it kind of impersonated
a four-wheel drive.
Did it already have the size tires on it?
Yeah.
Okay, yes, so it was like
larger tires than it needed
and larger than you would see,
like if you saw this truck,
and you are not from the South-
It's a little truck but the
size is a little too big.
You'd be like, "Okay that's a
redneck driving that truck."
Yeah, and that resonated with
me because that's who I was.
And my pop-pop took me to
see it, I believe one day.
And this is in the fall
and then that was it.
And then how did this happen?
Okay, then I noticed it
was gone from the lot.
You can see where this is going,
he bought me the truck, okay.
That's where the story is going,
but how did this...
It was gone from the lot,
and then I think I had this theory
that my papa had bought me this truck,
but it was pretty early before Christmas.
And my birthday is in June,
so I had a little doubt,
but I did have an inkling.
And then let's see it's Christmas,
I believe what happened was
it was Christmas morning.
Oh, and I told you that I thought I had.
I'm gonna be honest with you
and to tell you that I don't remember
being involved on this
side of the process.
I told you that I thought I
might be getting this truck.
And then what had happened was,
you were told that I was gonna
be surprised with this truck.
You were given the information.
Why did they tell me?
Because either my mom or my papa
or somebody was just so
excited about this gift.
It's just like, I assume Jesse is,
as excited as she is, she's
probably told Christy.
That's why I'm not gonna
ask her what your gift is,
'cause I don't wanna
have that information,
and I've already pushed the button.
I'm sure that if they told me
that I'll just turned around and told you.
I can't remember that part,
if you told me ahead of time.
But the part that I do remember.
I'm not good, I'm actually,
I'm a tight secret holder.
You tell me something.
And if you tell me that you
don't want me to tell anybody
As a 15-year-old?
I don't know
what I was like at 15.
You were 16 at the time.
I don't know what I was like at 16.
Now, I will take something to my grave.
Oh yeah.
I do not snitch.
I'm really good at that too.
I take pride in that.
Again, it's the button.
I'm really good at it
because I pushed the button
and I don't remember it.
I totally remember it,
and I always want to say it
when I'm around the person
who I know is the person
who needs to hear it
or would want to hear it.
I'm able to compartmentalize so much
that I legitimately no
longer have the knowledge.
That's dangerous, man.
That's like not knowing you
have a gun in your pocket.
Yeah know what I'm saying?
Well, I have it, I use it with discretion.
That's dangerous, man.
It has bit me in the
butt a couple of times.
Yeah, right?
'Cause you're like, oh,
I didn't remember that
I wasn't supposed to remember that.
Yeah, it's like, keep a secret
is different than forget you know it.
So, I am questioning my technique.
On Christmas morning,
I'm at home with my mom, opening
presents, stuff like that.
Having the whole Christmas
thing, I get a phone call.
It's you?
Hi Link.
And my mom's in the
room, I answer the phone.
I'm talking to you, I'm like,
"Hey man, Merry Christmas.
What'd you get? What I get?"
And then you start then
you're like, "Did you get it?
Did you get the big red surprise?"
Whether we had talked about
it ahead of time or not.
At that point, you
assumed that I'd gotten it
because it was Christmas morning,
but I don't go to my nana and papa's house
until Christmas night.
I didn't understand your
complicated family traditions.
So you were like-
It could have been
anything, big, red surprise.
Let's just assume you were
that you were keeping the secret,
but also totally confirming the surprise.
You're like, "Did you get the big red..."
And here I am like-
You already knew that you
were gonna get this truck.
And I didn't want my mom to overhear
that you were spoiling it for me.
Well, there was no such thing
as speakerphone at the time.
My side of the conversation
had to be really veil,
I was like-
And I'm sure this went great.
Yeah, instead of saying like,
"I don't know what you're talking about."
15-year-old Link trying to manage
two people at once.
I was trying to figure,
'Cause it's like, "Yeah
man, you know what?
That's probably gonna be tonight.
You know I'm going to nana
and pop-pop house tonight.
I'm gonna get some more presents.
Some may be bigger and redder
and rednecker than others,
but I haven't gotten there yet."
You said something like that?
No, I have no clue what I said,
but that was the dance.
Hopefully you didn't say that
because your mom would
have known that you knew.
Exactly, and then she probably
wouldn't have told pop-pop
because this was his thing,
to like surprise me, huge surprise.
I get there that night,
everybody's opening the presents.
Lots of tradition, lots of family members.
By the time we get done with the presents,
he's like, "You may have noticed
that you got less presents this year
than you usually get every other year."
And I always love how
he would go into like-
Kind of a speech.
If you gave him the opportunity
to take the floor for something.
"You may have noticed that
you do not have as many gifts
this year, as you've
gotten in previous years."
It was like a political speech.
"Though all of your half
siblings and cousins
have gotten the same amount of gifts
that they've gotten in previous years.
Let's walk around, out back."
And I'm like,
now I have to act surprised
about this huge thing.
I wanna give him the gift
of me being surprised,
but I'm not, but I was still elated.
So I just channeled that,
you know I'm a performer.
He had it parked out back
and it's just one of those
car commercial things,
except a 1987 in 1994.
It's a 1994 commercial for
a 1987 Nissan pickup truck.
Yeah, and I got anything and
didn't know how to drive it,
'cause it was a stick.
A stick, yeah.
But he taught me
and that was a connection that we made.
And that truck is still in the family.
You know what?
That's the third pillar
of the McLaughlin plan
as president, okay?
Okay.
Pillar number one,
every fifth grader gets a herd
of goats or a sewing machine.
It's up to them.
Pillar number three,
because those are actually two pillars.
Yes, oh I'm tracking.
Pillar number three is every 16-year-old
has to get a manual transmission car.
It's a little lated now.
I believe in electric vehicles,
and so I don't know if there's
a way to implement this.
Electric race car.
Do you like the combustion engine,
we got to get rid of that sucker,
but we got to somehow
give kids electric cars-
Still got to have a shifter.
With the manual shifter
that completely makes it more difficult
because I think that
made you a better person.
Well, you got the paddles,
the shifter paddles.
The shifter paddles aren't anything, no.
Yeah that's true.
You got to learn how to operate a machine
in a way that is meaningful
and you gotta take care of goats.
Put them in the back of the truck.
I kept that truck all
the way through college,
hitting a tree, busting the radiator.
I mean like near death experience,
so much happened in that truck.
I almost died in that truck.
So many experiences,
I took that truck into marriage
and then eventually sold
it, well it died and-
Then you got a pretty
similar truck to replace it.
Yeah.
But it was a Toyota.
I got a Toyota.
It looked like a four-wheel drive truck.
Big wheels, but two wheel drive,
which really was like one wheel drive.
It was a Toyota pre-runner.
Yeah.
So it was a fake four-wheel drive truck
because I was cheap.
I didn't even get the
extend cab I was like-
It wasn't stick though, was it?
No, I like that little truck.
That was a good looking truck.
I wanna get a little truck again.
I actually-
Don't make little trucks anymore.
That Toyota, that style of Toyota.
Tacoma pre-runner are
bigger now than they were.
Like the the early aughts.
That's a really good truck.
Yeah I like going back to them.
My father-in-law had one of those
that I drove that's where I
learned how to drive a stick.
Speaking of that,
just because while you
just talking about this,
I am gonna talk about the
best gift that I ever got.
Oh, we'll do it.
Because it's the same gift that you got.
I don't know how long we
had been married, not long.
We were on staff at campus
crusade at the time.
So, we were not making a lot of money.
No.
And so definitely not in a position
to purchase a car for
ourselves that was not used
or really a gift from someone else
is what most of our cars
would have been at the time.
And Christmas morning, this was actually,
I believe this was 100% unexpected.
I remember it that way.
You didn't tell me
so that I could call you before you got it
and tell you you were gonna get it.
So we're at my in-laws
house for Christmas Day,
which is like two houses
down from my own house.
Oh no, at the time we wouldn't have been,
since it's before Locke was born.
So we would have been introduced,
we were living in Chapel Hill.
But anyway Chris and
Ashley, Jessie's sister
and her husband, our Key West buddies
were all inside the house.
And then we're opening smaller presents
and clothes and stuff like that.
You may have noticed.
And then they said there
was some sort of speech,
please go outside and we'd go outside.
And there are two, 2002 or 2003,
whatever year it was, was
the year that this was,
Mitsubishi Monteros.
Two, one was gray, one was burgundy.
One was burgundy and one was gold.
Ooh.
And they're exactly the same, brand new.
One of my father-in-law's
employees had driven them up
and put them in the
driveway next to each other.
And it was literally like,
which one do y'all want?
Like it wasn't this one's for you,
and this one's for you.
That's trouble, fight over the color.
I don't remember, it was an easy decision.
We took the burgundy
one, I don't know why,
and then I remember driving
to Christmas conference
because we always went
to Christmas conference,
which was the regional
conference for campus crusade.
The day after Christmas, we would drive,
we would drive on the 26th because we were
Emceeing the conference.
And I remember driving down Highway 40
and pulling up next to you and Christy.
In the highway in our
car that you did not,
I don't think you knew
that we had gotten it.
No.
And like honking the horn at you
and getting out to look over
and see our big ass SUV that
we just gotten for Christmas.
I mean, that was really unusual.
I mean, we drove the hell out of that car.
Then your tire blew out,
and we just kept going.
That didn't happen.
But that was the most unexpected
and most helpful-at-the-time
gift because it was like,
we really, we were getting,
we were thinking about having kids.
It was, we needed a car
and we couldn't afford one ourselves.
It hasn't gotten better
than that since then.
No sibling rivalry
except over colors.
You gotta give them the exact same thing.
You gotta be equitable.
Lauren, Hooksnpines tweeted,
"Maybe not the best, but
the most memorable gift.
My great aunt got me
the board game 'Sorry!',
six years in a row every
Christmas, not as a joke either.
Legitimately, she forgot
it's what she got me
each year before, the
irony was lost on her.
'Cause it's called, Sorry!.
Okay, there's a few
things to explore here.
How could you...
Yeah, it's like...
I think that this,
first of all as we get older,
sometimes the memory
begins to fade a little bit
and this is a legitimate
thing that could happen
and she could just have forgotten.
And apparently that's what happened-
But her thought patterns
stayed consistent.
That's fascinating.
That is what I question.
I think that she-
What does Lauren want?
I bet she want a board game.
Sorry! is probably the best one.
First of all, I'm taking
issue with two things here.
Number one, you've never said, Sorry,
like a Canadian until today.
Yeah, 'cause I was kind of impersonating
Lauren's great aunt, which
I never say aunt either.
I don't know-
You've been saying Sorry.
Sorry.
It's sorry,
if you're from North Carolina.
Yeah, I'm not being me right now.
Okay, but the second thing
is I think that this aunt
gives Sorry! to lots of people, man.
She got a bulk deal on, Sorry!,
She's got Sorries.
Somehow, she came into a lot of Sorries
and has maybe her system is off
and she doesn't know who's gotten what,
but Lauren is not the only person
who's receiving Sorries
from this great aunt.
I mean, there's no way that she just-
I mean that is the other possibility,
if she thinks about Lauren
and she thinks she'll love this game.
It is a great game.
I like the feeling of
that popper in the middle.
Yeah, any sort of physical
feedback that you can get.
It's very satisfying.
Yeah.
It is a great game.
And you don't lose the die,
'cause they're contained in that module.
This is a good time to,
I wanted to check in with
you on something, because-
You've been waiting for this,
you mean for the right
time to bring what up.
When I was in Kansas city recently
Locke and Shepherd and I took
a little drive into the city.
They'd never been to Kansas city.
We went to this, I think it's
called the River Market Area,
sort of outdoor market.
Shout out to the people at
the Brazilian restaurant.
I can't remember your name,
but you're a Mythical beast.
And you gave me a really
incredible sandwich
and then gave me some
cheesy Brazilian bread balls
or whatever they are.
Wow, not gonna forget that,
but there's a store there
that was a board game store,
big board game store.
Now I-
It's a tough business
Yeah, it is.
But it's also like
Pokemon cards and stuff too.
Okay, irons in the fire, that's
a good business technique.
It was a lot of square footage
for this kind of store,
but maybe it's just
because I'm so used to LA,
like if you're selling board games in LA,
they're gonna give you like 10 by 12,
that's it, that's all you
get, you know what I'm saying.
It's gonna be like a board game closet.
Right, but in Kansas City,
I guess you basically get
what it amounts to two radio shacks.
I don't know if your radio shack scale is
for your local radio shack,
if it probably doesn't exist anymore.
It doesn't.
But anyway,
I love the idea of board games.
And so does Shepherd.
And so we're looking at
all these board games
and I'm just thinking, "Man,
we should get one of these board games."
We're not gonna get one
because we have to fly back, et cetera.
But that brought me back to,
you kinda started getting into board games
during the pandemic.
And then there was this whole thing
about you're getting
a national parks game.
The pandemic, the kids are back in school,
Lily's off at college, has the board game,
has it died, has the dream died?
Funnily enough, I was
thinking this morning
that a holiday activity of ours
should be breaking up Parks.
And it would be a nostalgic event.
The Neal family had never
incorporated board games
into our everyday Neal activities,
I kind of like Survivor.
But I think...
Yes, it can be a nostalgic.
There's only so much time.
So yeah, I think it can
become a holiday thing,
but probably only Parks.
I think I could get...
Is that what you wanted to ask me about?
Yeah, I wanted to know,
do you still recommend it?
Yes.
And the question I have as a followup is
I think I could get just Shepherd into it.
Jessie is a wild card,
it depends on if she's got a lot going on,
Locke, forget about it,
he might step in for a
little bit, but could,
are there games where
just two people can play
and it's fun?
Well, first of all,
there is a single player version of parks
within the game.
Single player?
So you can just play by yourself?
I don't what that means but
that's not what I'm asking.
I'm asking are the good
board games, in fact-
I think you can play with two people,
yes, I think so.
I also might just do a
little Google search.
Just do that,
Best two-player-
Stop bothering me with
things that you can Google.
No I don't remember.
Two-player board games.
If you have any insight,
#EarBiscuits, just tag me.
I wonder what you can do
with six versions of Sorry! at once.
Like, is that like a mega Sorry!.
Well, I wonder if every single
one of the little bubbles
makes the same exact tone.
Bryant Alvarado said,
"My college roommate
gave me a case of Kraft spirals macaroni,
and cheese for Christmas one year."
A case.
Solid.
Love it.
"He gave me a barbecue sauce sampler
for my birthday the next year."
Nice, "One of the best
friends I've ever had."
Yeah, you didn't know
where that was going.
So that's pretty cool, Bryant,
You got a friend who knows you,
but it kind of makes me wanna discuss
our approach to gifting to each other.
We've got this, like the
main thing we go back to
is that one Christmas
when "Rocky V" came out, we each went to,
in my memory,
Sky City?
We went to Roses.
Roses.
And we were browsing the music section.
And we each decided that
we wanted "Rocky V".
So we just both bought that
soundtrack for each other.
Can you name one song on that album?
♪ From The Streets
coming to man a fighter ♪
♪ Doing the best that he can to survive ♪
Who is playing that?
♪ Yes the survival for the fittest ♪
♪ Strive for what is mine ♪
♪ The Lord be my witness ♪
I have no clue what artists saying that
because it was not a recognizable artist,
but I knew that song.
It was a rap song and
it was on the soundtrack
that you got me for
Christmas, so I memorized it.
Boy, I wish you would just
take that part of your brain
and apply it as other,
The other talent.
I'm telling you Man.
I mean, it's got some useless
knowledge in there, man.
There's no way-
You don't have any useless knowledge?
I could not remember any thing about that.
I don't know what the cover looked like.
It wasn't a good soundtrack.
Of course, it was "Rocky V".
What was the best Rocky
movie I've ever seen?
And the only one you've seen "Creed".
No.
Ever since Michael B Jordan's bodyguards
gave me the hard shoulder at that party.
I just can't go back to the B Jordan.
"Creed" came out before that.
Before you were body
checked by his body guard,
"Creed" was already out,
maybe even "Creed 2" was getting ready.
I like "Black Panther" a lot.
But we don't typically give
gifts to each other these,
well, okay, there's the two
versions of us that are,
there's blurred lines between the two.
There's the version that you see
in the holidays that we celebrate,
we celebrate each other's
birthdays in front of you
on the shows that we make.
And then when the birthday rolls around,
because we shoot things ahead
of time, it's kinda like,
"Oh, happy birthday, man".
I've already acted like I gave
you a gift on the internet.
That came out today.
Yeah.
And I don't think that
it's just, again, first,
I don't think it's either
one of our love language
to receive gifts.
Well and this is what Jesse
asked me all the time,
because she's like, is your like,
"We got to get something for your dad."
"We got to get something for your mom."
And I'm like, "Oh."
And she's like, "I want it
to be like more thoughtful.'
And I'm like, yeah, "That's great."
And then a lot of times we just
settled on Amazon Gift Card
or something like that,
which is for a lot of people is just like,
but that's actually what my
parents prefer in many ways.
And they honestly, they don't,
like my family doesn't
care as much about it.
Like I know that my dad
is not gonna be like,
"Oh man, you didn't think about me."
But we always give them
stuff, I'm just saying-
Bit I think for, we don't
give each other stuff
out of just an obligation and expectation.
And we've never discussed it actually.
It's just that usually it doesn't happen.
There's been some times when,
I mean, like I remember for your birthday,
I got you that Hawkman poster one time.
And then I got you a wooden holster
that would like charge your
Apple watch and your phone.
And I was in kind of
a mindset of like, it.
No, no, it wouldn't charge it.
Oh, it was a piece of crap.
No, it was just a piece of wood
that you sit your phone in it-
And like if you ran the cable through it.
Yeah, it was a wooden holster,
It was only wood.
He likes wood, he has an Apple watch.
I'm gonna give him this,
but it was a piece of crap.
I was experimenting a
couple of times with,
am I gonna become a gift giver because,
and I think it was, do I
wanna be a gift receiver?
And do I want Rhett to give me gifts?
And then I discovered by giving you gifts,
the thing I discovered
was it didn't resonate
with either one of us.
I think that the biggest thing,
and it's not about our love language.
Is the reason why we don't
give each other gifts
is we know how difficult
it is for each of us
to get up the gumption,
to give gifts in general.
And I think we believe that
we're on the same page,
that the amount of work that
we would have to put in is more
than the amount of enjoyment
we would get from receiving.
It's like we kind of have this
unspoken thing that's like,
we both don't want, we don't have,
it takes a lot of time and energy,
especially this time of year.
Like what you were talking
about to like give gifts.
You're not, neither one of
us really have felt need
for that so it's like,
let's just spare each other the trouble.
Well, it's interesting
because, I honestly don't,
like if somebody gives
me a good thoughtful gift
I think it's really cool,
but I don't expect it.
I don't expect it from you.
I've gotten, I can't recall because again,
my memory doesn't work in this way,
but if I've seen some
things I've been someplace
and I've seen something
that's like around my birthday
or whatever there's a
couple of like examples
that are kind of analogous to what you did
with the Hawkman thing that you,
I can't remember what they are.
I will clarify,
I think I found the Hawkman poster
because I was looking for stuff
to decorate our office at the time
and I was like, you know what?
Rhett would like this and it
fulfills a desire that I have
to have our office decorated.
So it was kind of like me controlling
how you decorate your part of the office.
So like, I'll take that then just like,
it was kinda like
I had another interest in
giving the poster maybe.
But I think one of the things
I'm discovering though,
is that when I find something,
I'm gonna use the example of
what I found for Stevie for her birthday.
When I find something and I'm like,
"Oh man, this is perfect
and they're gonna love it."
I get a lot out of that,
And I think it taps into
the same thing that I like,
when I like cooking for
somebody, it's just like,
they're gonna think, they're
going to have this sandwich
and it's gonna be this great experience
and we're all together.
So if whether or not.
If you're talking about
the Liquid Death, sweats
outfit that you got?
Stevie is absolutely
obsessed with Liquid Death,
the drink which is just water.
It looks like you're
drinking like a tall boy,
malt liquor, so don't drive with it,
but it's just water,
it's really good water,
and she just loves it,
and she's always drinking
one, she's very hydrated.
And I just saw on Instagram-
You weren't looking for a gift for her.
No, I'm just scrolling Instagram
and all of a sudden, I
see this Liquid Death
long sleeve shirt and it's just like...
I don't know, I got an
abnormal heart rate detected.
Are you okay?
I'm sweating.
Maybe it's 'cause I had
my collar up too long.
Let me check mine.
Let's see where I'm at
right now, I'm at 74.
Why are you making this about you?
I'm just wondering,
is there something that we should be...
In the room?
Is in the room that we
should be worried about?
I'm at 97.
Oh, good Lord, I'm under a little stress.
I see this long sleeve shirt
and then I start scrolling
through the wheel or whatever, Carousel.
And it's like, there's
a hat, there's a hoodie.
There's matching sweat pants.
And I'm like, this has got a
Stevie written all over it.
And the timing was right.
And his birthday was coming
up in like a week or two.
I saw an ad.
And by the way, she absolutely loved it
and felt really like
thought of and appreciated.
And I'm not saying-
I told her I found it.
Yeah.
And we don't do that for
Stevie every single year.
We always get her something
for her birthday, I think.
It usually doesn't matter.
But it's like,
It usually doesn't resonate.
It usually is like,
"Here's a gift certificate
to something or whatever."
'Cause it's tough to find the things
that connect with the person.
But I saw an ad for
something that I was like,
this has got Christy written all over it.
And I was like, you know
what, I'm gonna buy it.
This is not something I,
I've only recently started
buying stuff from ads.
And by the way, we're gonna do an episode,
our 2021 purchases,
that's something we're
starting to do every year.
So that's coming up.
That's going to be fun.
Yeah. I was like, you know what?
I'm just, I really like this,
she'll really like this and I'll order it
and I'll give it to her for Christmas.
And now I'm thinking I'm
just going to go ahead
and give it to her now.
I think it would be more of a surprise,
but then I got to start
over for Christmas.
So maybe I'll keep it,
it's already wrapped.
I'm kind of itching to
just give it to her.
I don't know what I'll
get it for Christmas then,
but it's a thing that like
she could already enjoy now.
I mean, I'm not going to say what it is,
even though I don't think
that she's listening.
When you find that stuff,
man, you gotta go for it.
College roommates who give gifts,
I think that's sweet.
Here's another friend gift thing
that I thought was creative.
This is Aaronklemmensen,
thanks for tweeting at us.
"My roommate, my senior year of college
filmed a little bit of almost
every day of our senior year.
He put it together like
a vlog that needed,
that ended up being over
an hour and a half long.
Having the ability to go back now
and enjoy some of those moments
again is truly special."
Very cool gift idea.
And it's a gift that he was
able to give to himself too.
Ain't no shame in like a gift
for you is a gift for me.
I agree with this.
Like that Hawkman poster.
I don't know if it's called like what?
The one second, One second a day
or One Second app or whatever.
One of our good friends has done that.
I think we end up talking about
it every year, by the way.
Yeah, this is probably the third year
that we've talked about it,
but still never done it.
But this that's an hour and a half.
That's ambitious.
But also you get a
little bit more context,
than just the one.
The one second thing is
great because it's just like,
okay, it's 365 seconds
and we're done with it.
But I do think that these man, I mean,
this is kind of this kind of ties in
with what we've been talking about
with getting some
footage of your relatives
over the holidays, telling stories,
it's so easy to commemorate things.
And if you don't know
where we were talking about
that was,
we do carpool vlogs on every
month on the Mythical Society.
So like a, just a 20 minute conversation.
I think it's kind of like
an "EarBiscuit" in the car,
but you don't.
I think it's like an
"EarBiscuit" in a car,
but I think that that's
the wrong way to brand it,
which is a separate conversation now.
Anyway, that's what we were talking about.
I will say.
Recording
your elder relatives
stories for the past year.
But you know that,
I'm sure Google is doing the
same thing and other services,
but Apple is basically doing,
they're basically creating
these memories, right?
Like, oh, on this day,
November 18th, 2016,
like what happened on that?
Google Photos does it too.
I was actually looking at it this morning.
I'm just gonna play.
Where is it?
Oh, there's Lincoln and Lily.
Oh, this just in Hawaii.
There we are, there's me, the waterfall.
Yep, this is, so there's.
I mean, this is our Thanksgiving trip.
We got into the helicopters.
Tell me what you've been thinking
about Hawaii so far?
Don't touch it.
So that's Lando not
answering your question.
Oh, this is cool.
I mean, this is like,
'cause I don't want to
take the time to do this.
What in the world is that?
A steering wheel of something.
It was my leg, it was
my bare leg in a car.
Peer Pressure I think-
This is us going for a hike.
I get the idea.
Well, I guess what I'm getting at
is that what this friend took time to do,
big brother is now doing it for us.
The cloud does automatically.
Like, we don't need to curate our lives
because the computers are doing it for us.
And there's probably a like,
give me my summary of the year.
I mean, you probably don't
even have to ask for it.
It was gonna happen, it's
probably happening right now.
But I'm not saying
you can email it-
this is not a thoughtful
gift, I'm just saying that-
Put it on VHS for your grandparents.
Okay, I just kind of relived,
our Hawaii 2016 Thanksgiving.
We went together as family,
how often do I think about that?
Not very often.
Everyday.
I do.
But now here it is,
it's a memory I'm on my phone
and I could send that to
everybody in your family,
everybody in my family
and they would be like,
"Thanks for taking the time to do that."
I put a little something together.
All I did was literally open
an app and hit a button.
Yeah, there's a button.
Is it share, you could send
it to the group right now.
Mystina Mashek,
"A personalized song by the
lead singer of my favorite band
from my husband for Christmas.
It makes me so happy each
time I listen to it."
I don't know what your favorite band is,
so they're either-
Maybe a Local thing.
Either this is a-
This is Cameo on musical steroids,
or this is a low-level band.
This is either Cameo, this
isn't a very accessible band,
or this is a big band,
there's a connection between,
that the husband has,
either way it makes her happy
every time she listens to it.
The Cameo version of that,
the thing that we're pushing
for the Cameo montage stuff,
I think is akin to this.
Yeah and it's losing its,
it's kind of losing its
luster a little bit now,
as everyone begins to understand that
this doesn't take a whole
lot of work, it's a system.
It takes money and-
But it's still a very
meaningful at the point of sale,
as a point of sale but
the point of experience.
Speaking of thoughtful
experience, Tyler Reese,
FinalKickening tweeted, "I
had the goal of visiting
all 50 states before I turned 30,
which was interrupted by COVID,
on my birthday I woke up to
the house decorated by my wife
with things from my three missing states.
And the rest of the day
was spent doing activities
and eating food from those states.
So thoughtful.
Very thoughtful,
very sweet.
So experiential.
I love the fact that Tyler
had this idea, first of all,
to get to all 50 states before 30,
I assume that being in
trapped inside your home
and just eating food from,
I'm wondering what three states it was
that he hadn't been to.
Alaska is probably one of them.
Like if you have to just stay.
I bet it's not.
But Hawaii.
No, I bet it's...
You think it's like a Vermont?
Yeah.
Rhode Island?
I haven't been to Rhode Island.
I don't want to throw The
Dakotas under the bus,
but I'm thinking Dakota.
It's easy to miss a Dakota.
It's easy to miss both Dakotas.
South Dakota?
I'm sorry Dakotas is easy to miss you.
Which one has Mount Rush-less?
That one's tough to work
up the gumption to go to.
On a closing note,
I thought that this one was a very sweet
from Rachel Holmberg.
"When I was three, I got a
mini recliner that matched-"
Okay stop there.
First of all, a mini recliner is a thing.
Of course it is.
And this is a great gift
for anyone who's three.
Well, not only are mini
recliners or thing, but have you,
I'm surprised that you
guys haven't done this
at your house yet, but lots of people,
and it seems a lot of
people with Dachshunds
are making little living rooms.
If they have multiple
Dachshunds in their home,
they're like making little
living rooms with miniature,
like couches and table,
I haven't seen this.
furniture and artwork around
that's all lower level.
And it's like in a room in their house,
and to give a room to a dog.
But I mean, you got one kid in college.
You can take Lily's room
and make it a dog room.
I don't know.
Okay. Start over.
I interrupted.
When I was three I got a mini recliner
that matched my grandpa's.
We would watch TV and
eat our nightly ice cream
next to each other in our recliners.
My grandpa was my best pal
and my only father figure growing up.
Miss him every day.
Oh, that's so cute and poignant.
My grandfather sat in his recliner.
It wasn't necessarily as inviting
as it seems that your grandfather was,
'cause he just sat in his recliner,
chewing on a cigar, drinking something.
I think he just drank wine.
My grandma just drank whiskey.
She always smoked
cigarettes and drink whiskey
and he would smoke a cigar
and drink something else.
But I think it was wine.
And he had a little poodle that
would sit right next to him,
Honeybun.
Right up on him like that.
There is a thought that
if I had a little recliner
to go back and I have
my little candy cigar
and my little apple juice.
And your little fake poodle,
your little Honeybun.
'Cause there was no ice
cream eating in that chair,
and once he had a cigar and wine,
he didn't eat anything.
I don't know what he ate.
Maybe it was whiskey
too, but mama Neal buddy.
She would have some
whiskey every single night.
I didn't understand that
that was a probably a problem
until much later in life.
I think this is such a sweet memory
and sometimes it's like,
gifts that you can go
back to in your brain
because if it's a three-year old recliner,
you're not actually going
back to the recliner.
It could be an attic somewhere.
I like that.
You could put your Dachshund
in it when you grow up
and put that on Instagram.
Well, thank you for
sharing your gifts with us.
The stories of your gifts.
May your gift giving be
especially thoughtful.
I got a rec.
Give it to us.
My gift to you, the gift that
you can give to yourself,
a musical pick-me-up.
Enjoy that "Silk Sonic" album,
Anderson Paak, Bruno Mars,
super group Silk Sonic.
You got some Bootsy Collins,
Legend kind of narrating a story
that lasts about 31 minutes.
You got a little bit of
Thundercat in one song,
which is cool.
But yeah, it's just a syrupy
retro soul funk good time.
So if you need that, pick-me-up,
give yourself that gift
this holiday season, little
bit of the "Silk Sonic".
Get in your recliner, grab your ice cream,
your earbuds and listen
to your heart's content.
#EarBiscuits, tell us what you think.
Talk at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.